how about a little music with your meal
Q music
[Music]
brunch now
where we go we want to be able to hear
what George mutzinger has to say you're
the corporate chef of his songs uh
everybody knows you guys for your
margaritas your incredible meals great
vegetarian vegan selection but now
you're doing brunch and you're doing it
with Mariachi yes ma'am we are every
Sunday from 10 to 2 just to start if
everybody likes it it'll be expanded
some more days excellent okay so 10 to 2
on Sundays and you've got a whole
variety of different kinds of foods
let's talk about what you're making here
right here I'm making elote grits so we
take everything that's in the dish of
elote okay one carbs we make a corn
stock cook the grits and corn throw
grilled corn inside we do the cheese
tahin and we throw a little shrimp on
top with a poached egg oh my goodness so
this is the fancy Mexican style brunch
yes okay take things that you would
normally have and just play with it a
little like uh we have the
eggs benedict over here normally comes
with an English muffin but we use
soapies oh look at that beans Carnitas
and our hollandaise is at Chipotle
hollandaise okay so it's got a would you
say a little bit of
to it a little just a little bit okay A
little bit too much okay so a little
flavor there it won't hurt you for those
who don't want to maybe have any meat
with their breakfast they can go with
what what is that sure waffles so we
make the waffles ahead of time and then
we fry them just like a churro pull them
out toss them in cinnamon and sugar
drizzle it with a salted caramel oh oh
oh I'm messing up a little bit of
whipped cream and then macerated
strawberries to finish it off in
powdered sugar wow okay so for folks at
home again tend to two is a brunette who
songs this is at Boca Park yes and it is
a plated brunch so this is not buffet
style this is go in pick an amazing meal
and uh we have to talk about the drinks
as well yes ma'am that's important part
of brunch the Bloody Mary even comes
with uh food we have a candied pork
belly and shrimp oh wow does it come in
this glass yes this is like lifting away
22 to 24 ounces okay your Margarita pure
Bloody Mary this will do your Sunday and
you said this is uh what these were
chicharon or pork belly Port belly
they're cooked with honey and brown
sugar okay wow that's great Margarita
and then of course you've got your
mimosas
that makes me want to sing Chef all
right
thank you so much for being on the show
this morning guys thank you all right I
appreciate it I'm gonna have myself a
drink here bye